- Hey guys, I know I look like
the Emperor from
Star Wars right now,
but I’m very high
in the air back
from London headed
to New York City.
I’ve decided to
do a video mainly
because I’ve caught
up with my email,
and I don’t like wasting
time and I figured, you know,
it’s 2012, it’s early, boy,
my eyebrows look insane.
It’s early in the year and
I figured it’s almost February,
I’m clearly not
excited about football,
the Super Bowl's
coming up, and I figured,
you know what, why don’t I rant,
make a little
GaryVaynerchuk.com video,
see if I could bring any value.
I just read a bunch of emails.
I get a lot of emails
from entrepreneurs who are
looking for advice, trying
to figure out how to make it.
And I think about
a lot of things,
especially on these flights
when I get a lot done
and I’m just thinking,
thinking about my life,
thinking about what
I want to accomplish.
And I figured,
you know, hit record,
see what comes
out of this, see if
there’s any value for anybody.
I think people
underestimate DNA a lot.
I think that a lot of my success
happens because
I was born with it.
I also think that people
underestimate
how insanely obvious
it is for some people
and how murky it is for others.
What I mean by that is, it’s
always been obvious to me,
it's always been obvious what
caused success,
what I needed to do.
Every time I watch content
through the internet
or on television, or watched
Oprah the other night,
Lizzie was watching
and I was working.
She was interviewing
George Lucas.
And he was saying the same
shit, same shit I always say,
same shit I hear from
everybody who wins.
I think the fear
of losing trumps
the excitement of victory
for so many people.
I think people are so scared.
It’s kind of like
hitting on girls.
I get it, right,
because I kind of was
more scared of hitting on girls
than I was in
winning in business.
I was much more fearless in
executing business models
than I was about going up to
a girl and getting shot down.
Nobody wants the rejection.
Nobody wants to lose.
So I understand the philosophy,
I understand that string of DNA
that doesn’t want
to make you lose,
but I’m so desperate
to figure out how
to convince people that there
is no loss in going for it.
That yeah, you might
get made fun of,
and you might have it
in your own mind,
but trying to figure
out how to make people
drop that fear of
going and building
a business for
themselves in 2012,
trying to figure out
how to make a video
or give a talk or send a tweet
or write a book,
just something that
makes people understand that
executing the way it always is,
following the school
business model,
which is such horseshit,
is gonna lead you to a place
where you’re not going to win.
Or that is a place where
you’re going to win,
meaning some people are
meant to be B and C players.
Some of you are not meant
to, you know, go out and win.
I think this whole like,
"If you try,
"it will come to you,"
is such horse shit.
I’m worried that people
are confused that effort
or the secret or hustle is
enough because it’s not,
it’s part of the equation,
but talent and skills
and the ability to work hard
and having a thick skin.
Do you know how
obnoxiously thick
my skin is when
it comes to business?
I don’t give a fuck what
anybody says about me
or thinks of me or
thinks what I’m
doing when it comes to business
because I trust my intuition
one kadrillion percent.
I know that I’m built to win
when it comes to business.
I always win.
I’m gonna win, and people
that don’t understand my style
or don’t think that I’m
doing the right thing
or think that
VaynerMedia's a dumb
idea 'cause it's
client services,
they just don’t know me.
They don't understand
what I'm going to do.
They don’t understand
that it's early.
People just don't
understand how early it is.
I’m 36.
I’m a kid.
Shit, would I want to
be 25 like A.J.?
Fuck yeah, but I’m 36.
In six years, I’ll be 42.
Do you know how much I’m gonna
do in the next six years?
I just worry that people
don’t have patience.
I worry that people don’t
tap into their strengths.
My strength is
that I tell stories.
My strength is that
I understand people.
My strength is that I understand
how to build
organizations to succeed.
My strength is that I
understand that people is what,
are what the foundation
of any business is.
My strength is that
I give a crap.
Yeah, I care about myself more,
but I actually care
about you as well.
My strength is that
I'm a communicator,
that I’m showman,
that I know how to brand,
that I’m willing to
work ridiculously hard,
that I have intuition of
where things are going,
that I work tirelessly
to listen to people
that I think know
where things are going,
that I engage,
that I genuinely care,
that I’m willing to sit here
right now and make this video,
hoping that one fucker,
one fucker says,
“Oh shit, yeah, like fuck it.
"Fuck Mom.
"Fuck Professor Tom.
"Fuck what the intuition
of other people is.
"I’m gonna listen to mine.
"The establishment, the
blueprint, fuck all that.
"I’m just gonna
listen to myself."
Listening to yourself
always wins.
Do I have angst?
Sure, I’m calling out
myself every day
for the last six or seven years,
telling everybody
I’m gonna buy the Jets.
I'm gonna roll billies deep.
36, getting older,
worrying about the time,
but still, betting on patience,
betting on I’ve been right,
betting that
I get better every year, betting
that the 2006 version of me
that was so cocky, that
ruled with massive bravado
is a punk compared
to the 2012 version
of me 'cause that’s the truth.
You keep getting better.
I’m betting on that I continue
to listen, continue to stay
humble while still being
obnoxiously confident.
I’m betting that
the world’s changing,
and I’m paying attention,
understanding that you’ve got
to play that Moneyball game,
which means data's the game,
but putting EQ on
top of that matters.
Betting that all the
good that I’m trying
to give everybody
comes back to me,
that somebody that
I affected opens a door for me.
Betting that the people
I’m networking with now
on a daily basis from
9 P.M. to two in the morning
open up doors, open up
opportunities, open up my mind.
Betting that the work
I put in operationally
on VaynerMedia is
gonna pay dividends.
Is it sexy?
No.
Am I turning down
things like TV?
Yes.
Am I less famous,
little more quiet,
little more off the grid?
Absolutely.
Am I happy that I’m
executed and that I’m making
shit happen and
I’m building a business?
One kadrillion percent.
Betting on a lot
of things, my friends,
betting on a lot of things,
but most of all,
betting on my community.
Community is the
last great asset.
When you play all
these chess moves out,
it's gonna be
the only thing left,
the people that
give a shit about you
and the people that
you give a shit about.
And they’re gonna open
up the opportunities,
the doors, the business
opportunities,
the life opportunities,
and I'll always bet on that.
I believe in that 'til the end.
And so I sit here and
give this seven-minute,
37-second rant to
you because I think
real and authentic
and honest matters.
I think I’m good enough to win.
And I think you’re good
enough to win at your level.
Am I gonna win at the ultimate,
biggest guy of all time,
Gates, Zucks, Buffett?
Probably not.
Am I more charismatic and loving
and more interesting
than those characters?
I think so.
Do I have enough to
get me to a billy?
I think so.
But is that 40 billion?
No.
Are you good enough to get to
a hundred thousand, 400,000?
I think so.
I just sat here and read a
hundred emails from people,
“Oh, makin' 40, 50K,
30K, read Crush It!,
"read Thank You Economy,"
got inspired by me.
But I was a spark.
I was the one that
had that insane thing
that I have in me that
made them say, “Hmm.”
You know, things that
make you go, “Hm.”
'80s reference, sorry.
But then they had it in them.
And so when I make this video,
what’s coming from my heart
right now is maybe
you’re watching this
and saying, “Hmm,
maybe I need to hedge."
If you work from 8 P.M.
to four in the morning,
will your dreams come true?
No, you might
not be good enough.
You might have not picked
the picked the right product.
But are we living in
a world in 2012
that’s so much better than
your parents' and grandparents'
and great grandparents'
generation,
because assholes like
me can make videos
when I’m 30,000
fucking feet in the air?
Yes.
And because of that, and
because of those opportunities,
and because we're
networked in a way
we’ve never seen before and
because sending an email
to a hundred people
and one will answer
and give you a shot matters,
because of that opportunity,
because of 2012, I beg you,
I beg you to take a shot.
Roll up on that hot chick
at a bar and ask her out.
Roll up on that good-looking
dude and ask him for coffee.
Roll up on your business
idea and make it happen.
Because being 50, 60, 70, 80, 90
and having regrets
that you didn’t
swing the bat is
the worst of them all.
Our at-bat is in front of us.
Take a swing.